let's say that you're the owner of some
type of copyrighted material maybe it's
a movie maybe it's music of some kind
and you observe that there is a site
that is operating outside of the United
States and that site at least in your
mind seems to be infringing on your
copyrights by US law so this is the site
this is the site in question and you are
saying that it's doing illegal things at
least at least by US standards the
problem is is that there's nothing you
can do it's operating outside of US soil
and outside of US laws you can even go
to the government even if the government
wanted to do something about it it
really couldn't because once again it is
outside the US jurisdiction the purpose
of SOPA and it seems fairly benign at
first is to give some tools to these
actors to stop this the problem and
we'll see that it's actually quite a
large problem is it gives tools to these
actors to do much more than just
stopping illegal activity it allows them
essentially to go on to some degree a
kind of a witch hunt for anyone that
might even have a whiff of enabling this
type of activity it won't even just be
for foreign sites so let's write this
down so SOPA stands for Stop Online
Piracy Act it sounds pretty reasonable
and this is the version of the bill
that's coming from the House of
Representatives the one from the Senate
they're slightly different but they have
the same intent is PIPA and what it does
is if you can't go after the this site
itself maybe you can go after site that
are somehow benefiting this site and
those sites are inside the United States
so this is outside this is inside the
United States
so things that are doing that might
include search engines so search engines
like a Google or Bing
they obviously link to this site over
here you might have ad networks so sites
that allow this site over here to
display ads and get revenue from them
that are benefiting this site over here
you might have payment sites like PayPal
or credit card processors that this site
uses to collect revenue and maybe most
importantly you have things like the DNS
servers within the US that associate
this site's domain name with the actual
servers and
don't get too technical about it but
when you type in something like WWJD
shady foreign and once again where we're
going to see that this site might not
even have to be shady or foreign but
when you type something like that in
there servers in the United States that
associate that with these servers that
might be operated outside the United
States that associate these this text
with a number that points to this
website that points to this websites
servers so these are all things within
the United States that to some degree
this site is dependent on so what SOPA
does is it allows these actors here the
ones that are obviously concerned with
enforcing with enforcing their
copyrights to issue court orders and
notices to these actors right over here
that essentially compels them very
strongly to immediately cut off ties to
immediately cut off ties with this
illegal site or this person what they
think is an illegal site now that might
seem reasonable to you except for the
fact that it's kind of a shoot first and
think later type of policy the basic the
way it works is is you presume guilt
until this guy somehow tries to prove
his innocence and we'll see this guy
isn't just nationally sites outside the
US it might even be completely legal or
what I would consider completely legal
sites inside the US essentially as soon
as this allegation is made in either a
court order or notice is paid these
enablers have to cut off ties to this
site and you can imagine if these cut
off ties to this site this site's
business whatever it might be whether
illegal or illegal immediately gets
obliterated especially this one here
including search engines ad networks and
payments and if they don't comply then
these guys are going to start having a
legal battle and so these guys are not
only going to have to comply and that by
itself is hard but if they don't comply
they themselves are going to be in
trouble now it gets really obviously
creepy when you start going into so when
you think of just a spirit you're like
okay maybe this is you know we can we
can work around this a little bit but it
gets creepy when you even though this is
the spirit of the legislation when you
actually read the wording of the
legislation and obviously that's what
matters not the name or the intent but
actually how its worded and when it the
way it's worded it's pretty clear that
its intent is
to go after much more than just a site
that's explicitly selling illegal
pharmaceuticals or allowing people to
download movies or or video of movies or
music that these owners don't have
access to but when you read the wording
it's pretty clear that they want to be
able to shut down anything that isn't in
any way associating with itself or in
any way enabling it and you see it in
the wording so this is actually section
103 of the SOPA legislation and this is
how they define a site that is dedicated
to theft of us property so an internet
site is dedicated to the theft of us
property if and so you know it's it's
usable by people in the United States
and then this is interesting it's that
it's primarily designer operated for the
purpose of has only limited purpose or
use other than or is marketed by its
operator or another acting in concert
with that operator for use in offering
goods or services in a manner that
engages in enables or facilitates now
this is interesting enables or
facilitates all of these violations and
these are the violations that would be
you know illegal you're selling things
that you can't sell your you're
infringing on other people's copyrights
and it might seem harmless this enables
or facilitates until you think about
what that could encapsulate if I have a
site I mean I guess I am part of a site
Khan Academy let's say someone puts a
message on Khan Academy and from Khan
Academy from Khan Academy they link to a
site that actually is really illegal and
that is really shady they link to it and
in the message boards well under this am
i enabling is Khan Academy enabling or
facilitating and if that's the case and
Khan Academy by this definition would be
considered to be a site that is
dedicated to theft of us property and
there are much bigger players and just
Khan Academy that can be thrown into
this bucket players like YouTube or
Vimeo or any site or even a news site
that allows people to put comments or
allows people to put images things like
Flickr that maybe hat in some way the
user is infringing on the copyright now
all of a sudden the whole site based on
this definition the entire site can be
defined as a site dedicated to theft of
us property by this definition YouTube
could be that if it's viewed
kind of you know enabling or
facilitating Khan Academy any new site
could be viewed like that way Vimeo
could be viewed that way a photo sharing
site could be viewed that people might
take a photo of something they don't
have the copyright to and upload an
image and all of a sudden what with this
by this definition based on just a sense
that that's being violated
they won't just be able to shut down
these blatantly illegal sites they will
be able to shut down things like YouTube
or Vimeo or even things like cnn.com if
someone puts a message or an image that
they think is somehow violating and so
it's not just going right now the
methodology is if there's some content
on YouTube or Vimeo or some other site
that they feel is infringing on their
copyright there are laws where they
contact YouTube directly they point them
to the content that seems to be
infringing and then YouTube or Vimeo or
whoever will take down that content but
what this allows them to do is shoot
first and think later oh look you are
enabling that if they can convince some
court to give a court order even they
can start start giving notice to these
players right over here to cut off ties
with major what I would consider very
legal sites like YouTube or Vimeo or CNN
it's really almost any site that allows
people to upload things onto it or put
links on it which is almost Facebook is
another one Facebook anything that has
user-generated content if just a whim
they could take down the entire site not
just take down that user-generated
content they could out with convincing
just one judge or convincing just any of
these they can cut off ties with
Facebook not even making Facebook calm
point to Facebook anymore CNN they could
just completely take down these sites on
a whim and it gets worse than that
because you would say well like if
they're taking this down on a whim and
you know maybe they kind of thought it
was but they didn't do their homework
and they later realize that it wasn't
copyright infringement couldn't these
guys sue back although already the
damage would have been done these sites
would have been taken down they would
have lost millions or billions of
dollars millions or tens or hundreds of
millions of users would not be able to
access these things and this would also
be true for Wikipedia if someone
uploaded something that where it wasn't
completely hundred-percent vetted they
could take down the entire they could
take down the entire site not just that
content and you say okay that's bad
enough but couldn't these people would
say
look you wrongfully took us down we're
going to sue you now well to see that
they can't and to see how one-sided
legislation is notice the threshold for
being able to sued back if you kind of
misrepresented a violation the only way
you are kind of held accountable is if
you knowingly materially misrepresented
the violation so if the copyright holder
just says oh I think someone on YouTube
you know I feel pretty good that someone
on YouTube is violating it that YouTube
is enabling a violation and therefore
YouTube is a site dedicated to theft of
us property and it later on it finds out
that that it wasn't it was fair use or
maybe that person actually did have the
copyright to it they can't be sued
because they said well I just thought it
was they weren't they weren't knowingly
materially misrepresenting themselves so
even if it ends up not even being a
violation these guys could take the site
down maybe some small producer actually
secured the rights put it up on YouTube
and then all of a sudden these guys take
down in all of YouTube based on not
actually knowing what they're talking
about and they can't even there can't
even be a countersuit in that case based
on the law and it gets even creepier
than that because to be considered this
you don't even just have to enable or
facilitate which is almost anything one
could argue in a computer is enabling or
facilitating this on some level but you
could you are considered to be a site
dedicated to theft of us property even
if you do nothing illegal even if you
don't even enable anything illegal but
if you just take actions that make it
difficult for authorities to confirm
that you're doing something illegal so
if you view this in the physical world
obviously some people are doing illegal
things in their homes and obviously a
lot of people lock their doors to keep
people out of their homes and maybe
people doing illegal things are even
more likely to lock their doors and
close their shutters what this would do
and this would do it in the virtual
sense is say look by just by taking the
deliberate action of closing your
shutters and locking your doors which
makes it hard for federal agents to
confirm that you're doing illegal things
just by doing that that itself is an
illegal act so this is this is maybe one
of the creepiest and draconian
intrusions of privacy that I've actually
you know I've ever
that was even attempted to be passed
into law so I if I were you just as a
kind of a a privacy liberty-loving
American I'd be worried